oh
[Musique]
loin du japon le pays du soleil levant
1300 nippon vivent ici au pays de heidi
la plupart sont expats dans les
nombreuses organisations internationales
[Musique]
oh
tous les vendredis c'est à quelques
minutes de genève dans la commune d'onex
qu'une petite poignée d'entre eux
prennent d'assaut cette ville dortoir
[Musique]
à canet a quitté son île natale il y a
dix huit ans après avoir terminé ses
études de langues depuis elle a épousé
un suisse évite à genève une fois par
semaine elle rejoint ses compatriotes
pour chanter à pleins poumons
[Musique]
je vous somme qu'on chante ici c'est des
chansons confondues depuis l'enfance
tellement de bois dans cette chanson
pourquoi c'est très bon pour nous pour
la fiction elle étrangers et la chanson
qu'on connaît du bilan
jean
oh
[Musique]
oui
dans la culture traditionnelle japonaise
dame nature est omniprésente et depuis
la récente catastrophe de fukushima la
diaspora se mobilisent
[Musique]
téléjournal
diffuser l'image de thoune a mis le
séisme de toutes les maisons sont
ravagés comme ça par les vagues c'est
vraiment terrible cette année on fait
plusieurs concerts avec d'autres
chorales aussi pour récolter dedans et
puis après on en boit via croix-rouge au
japon pour
pour les efforts de reconstruction
après 2,6
[Musique]
rabat
plus qu'une nécessité au japon la
solidarité est un devoir et davantage
encore quand on est loin de sa patrie
[Musique]
contre le mal du pays un seul remède
pour les nippons de genève un bon coup
de baguette
direction vers soi à deux pas du lac
léman c'est ici dans le plus vieux reste
au japonais de genève qu'ils viennent
chatouiller leurs papilles et se
réchauffer le coeur on parlera
ce
tte dessous en acajou est un habitué des
lieux ce fonctionnaire japonais arrivé à
genève en 1973 et fréquente depuis cet
établissement
passée la friture de
délégués
et ce qu'il fait
ce soir tu es dessous a rendez vous avec
quelques amies japonaises pour parler du
bon vieux temps au menu tempura sushis
et sashimis
[Musique]
mumbai il ne faisait pas même pour 1
tasse de thé et les connaissances c'est
pas où sont les théières des choses
comme ça donc mais maintenant ça ça va
changer je pense on dit que appelé la
beauté de jeunesse c'est la cuisine qui
attire
les hommes qui peuvent garder ses mali
très traditionnel la société nippone
subi ces dernières années un profond
changement longtemps cantonnés dans leur
rôle de mère éducatrice à les femmes ont
souvent vécu à travers les résultats
scolaires de leurs enfants
quartier de plainpalais à l'école
japonaise de genève à canet a troqué son
costume de femme au foyer pour un job à
l'aéroport mais la réussite de sa filmo
et n'a pas de prix après l'école suisse
la semaine mots ils passent tous et
samedi à étudier ici le japonais
l'histoire et les mathématiques
deux enfants donc j'étais pense pour
l'année
un peu moins que quatre mines donc
financièrement elle veut un enfant
jusqu'à des universités voire master dr
comme ça c'est déjà assez un
investissement nécessaire pour à canet
mais aussi un bon business pour l'école
qui compte 310 élèves
aujourd'hui c'est la rentrée pour la
grande section en ce début de trimestre
le proviseur accueille les élèves en
musique
[Musique]
aussi m
il
il est l'heure d'ouvrir les livres pour
mot et ses camarades
pour pouvoir lire couramment le japonais
il est nécessaire de connaître plus de
2000 qu'angie des idéogrammes emprunté
aux chinois au quatrième siècle
c'est aujourd'hui que je fais le test
pour voir s'ils ont bien travaillé le
pas et à son camp est à retenir sa c5 en
transit à et créer puis 55 c'est à dire
dont cohésion de travailler à la maison
au japon la majorité des étudiants
effectuent le duke ou des cours du soir
indispensable pour intégrer un bon
collège un bon lycée puis une bonne
université
ottawa - santé cataracte batteur 1,5 à
l'autre ou non autour d'aullène stérols
de désengorger cette fraîcheur from
school pressure from pérenne
le japon détient bien triste record
celui du pays au plus grand nombre de
suicides chaque jour de l'année près de
deux étudiants décident de se donner la
mort victime d'un système scolaire
terriblement compétitif et impitoyable
pour évacuer le stress de leurs enfants
les japonais ont importé legault en
suisse un jeu quatre fois millénaire
inventé en chine mais qui a acquis sa
forme actuelle au japon au 16e siècle
c'est dans cette maison à deux pas de
genève que l'on retrouve tête sous l'eau
donc comment suivre son état n'est pas
adapté
trouvait devant lé dos tourné dans
quelle époque on aurait six mois yara
les
ttt dessous et professeur de go une fois
par mois il donne des cours bénévoles
pour faire partager sa passion et diallo
jean servat et aux monstres et le veau
est un
pays stratégique
il faut savoir partager
partager de tétouan mais même en perdre
à on n'est pas écrasé
al'inverse des échecs la philosophie
orientale impose au go de ne pas tuer
son adversaire ici le but est simplement
de posséder un maximum de territoires et
pour gagner à chacun sa méthode
les jeunes élèves de tetsuo ont attrapé
le virus
la planète go recense aujourd'hui plus
de 50 millions de joueurs
à genève tetsu enfin trouvé un
adversaire à sa taille le champion de
suisse et ce n'est pas quelques trombes
d'eau qui les empêcheront de se livrer
bataille au bord du lac